millions of americans desperate for
economic relief from the pandemic
they're going to have to wait until next
month at least congress is heading out
of town with no coronavirus stimulus
deal in sight
chad pergram is live on capitol hill
with this update chad good afternoon
dana well it's really remarkable that
there's no talks on coronavirus right
now considering the state of the
pandemic and the state of the economy
the thing that we're starting to hear
here on capitol hill is that they might
try
to put some sort of a coronavirus aid
package into a big spending bill to
avoid a government shutdown
in september that's why everybody is
looking at september but house speaker
nancy pelosi
is skeptical they said oh we all work
better up against the deadline no the
virus doesn't
have a deadline and nor does it take a
pause american people don't want this
uncertainty
so we can't wait until september 30th i
know some have said
well this will but people will die
they have to fund the government by
september 30th or face a government
shutdown that could be cataclysmic in
the middle of a pandemic
so despite what pelosi says september
could impose a pressure point for action
now the senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell kept the senate in session
last
week for just an hour or two each day in
hopes of an accord but mcconnell
formally dismissed everyone until
september 8
yesterday afternoon after the senate
adjourns
today we'll have our
regular pro forma meetings through the
end of the state work period it would
take bipartisan consent to meet for
legislative business
sooner than scheduled now the reason the
economy has performed reasonably well
the past couple of months is because
congress approved
big stimulus back in march and also in
may
but that's why they're very concerned
about the economic prowess or progress i
should say
as they go in to the fall dana back to
you